pat have you ever heard that perspective
before what he's saying is is
contradictory to basically what every
american has ever known which part the
part specifically about world war ii
we've been you know the greatest
generation is the name that everyone
uses for the parents of the baby boomers
the they were they fought in world war
ii
one-fifth west 45th east the royal
russia play that cost them is that is
that what you're talking precisely and
ultimately we've been raised that the
greatest generation of all time is the
world war ii generation you know the
baby boomer they raided this no the
parents of the the baby boomers they
raided the streets of nor the shores of
normandy and this is the epitome of
american culture and exceptionalism
and
your father fought in this war what kind
of backlash do you get from your father
or your father's
you know constituency his age from what
you're saying about world war ii very
key question and yeah would you mind
just pulling this closer to you because
i yeah you can even move that
i'm saying you can grab that like like
this
you're saying to move the mic a little
bit yeah yeah just so you can hear yeah
because what you're saying is very
important and it's contradictory to
anything we've ever heard about america
that's a great question
well thank you adam but
the
the
the concept
of the greatest generation is mythology
again it was invented as far as i know
by uh ambrose stephen ambrose who's a
a certain kind of historian very
patriotic
i believe it was ambrose but certainly
tom brokaw who uh interviewed me uh uh
made also
i remember him
using that expression and he wrote a
book about it
tom brady
now tom brokaw is a very nice liked
very much liked on the air but he is not
a very bright man in my opinion he
interviewed me on the kennedy
assassination for an hour and a half in
this
2013 the 60th anniversary i talked to
him very cogently as i'm talking now for
an hour and a half he he
they when they when they when they
released the uh the documentary
it was i was there for 60 seconds and it
was very superficial that's the kind of
treatment you get in major media in the
united states you know they cut to the
commercial
you can't have any serious discussion on
the air this is
this is so bad this is part of our
problem we don't think about things we
don't discuss
both sides of an equation
but the greatest generation is is a lie
and they would
they point to george
h.w bush oh he was he was a fighter
pilot he was a heroic man yes but what
look what happened he goes to war in
iraq
on the flimsiest of reasons
and there was a lot of doubts about that
1990 war and then we can go into that
but not here uh
and he's he was made a giant a lion of
that generation but he's not he's not he
was a he's a man who did his job in
world war ii and it was a tough war no
question about it but a lot of those
people if you go and talk to the actual
people who fought in the war will tell
you another story completely how filthy
and dirty it was and how sh i won't use
it was an obscenity it's a podcast you
can you can
it was not a pretty war it was
no one's proud of their service no and
they civilians are killed all the time
all kinds of cowardice all kinds of
infighting among the troops
the truth of war is that
and so we we have some kind of
you know the problem now we've sanitized
since vietnam we've sanitized the news
about war right you get embedded you
have to have journalists embedded safely
with the military in order to report
anything you're not allowed to show the
bodies coming back they hide them
iraq
and
afghanistan
we've sanitized tried to sanitize the
war now we're not even using troops
we're trying to use proxy nations and
send their armies to fight
so i i
we have to re-examine that
attitude that we have that we're number
one
we have to learn to live with other
nations
learn to cooperate
we don't have to be the most dominant
nation in the world i think we'd be
better off if we were a quieter and a
little and let other countries have
their power balances we need a balance
of power between people between
countries too
as in a family so if you enjoyed this
little segment from the podcast click
over here to watch the entire podcast
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so take care everybody
[Music]